um everybody Welcome to the uh
the
first virtual session at Simon's
Institute in Berkeley and
um it's great to see everybody here many
of you are here in person uh as well and
so you've already had a bit of an
introduction to The Institute for but
for those that are not the Simons
Institute is uh hosted by UC Berkeley
and runs uh programs in theoretical
computer science and also at at topics
at the intersection of theoretical
computer science and other fields and so
this Workshop that is taking place
physically in Berkeley this week is
focused on the economics of networks and
we have one fully virtual session uh
which has three fantastic speakers ASU
who's here and
um then we'll have a talk by Evan Sadler
and then by Dean Eckles and in between
the physical and uh I mean in between
the the talks there will be a half hour
coffee break where we will uh set it up
so that people can come in the physical
venue talk to others and in the virtual
venue talk to others I encourage you to
walk around and circulate and introduce
yourself to others you can sit at tables
when you watch the talks and thereby
chat with people at your same table
um so yeah this is an experiment of how
to another way to do hybrid and I
appreciate everybody uh like you know
being game to try it out so with that I
think we can get started with the
technical content also for people who
are physically here after the last talk
I'll facilitate
um the like lunch Arrangements if you
want to meet up with people for lunch
but uh in the meantime uh let's let's
start with the technical content I'm
very pleased to have ASU with us
um it's been it's fantastic that you
were able to join us and I think that's
largely because we were able to make a
virtual thing work out so so I love the
fact that this hybrid format enables us
to get great speakers that we might not
see otherwise
um and so I'm really excited to hear
asu's talk she'll be talking about
protecting privacy in new data markets
and so go ahead thank you can you hear
me Nicole and I'll hear you yeah okay
awesome thank you so much for having me
I would love to be there in person but
I'm so grateful you made this virtual
option possible uh it's such a terrible
time of the uh term uh to travel so this
made it possible for me to be with you
um so and I'm super actually delighted
that you're using this interesting
platform which I haven't used before
because I can see lots of people I know
here oh my God that's great to be with
everyone
um so today I'm going to talk about uh
some recent work uh that we're excited
about uh as Nicole mentioned this will
be about you know data sharing privacy
protections and you know thinking about
what kind of architecture should we be
thinking about from equilibrium and
optimality properties
um so this is why it's recent work uh a
couple of different uh papers we're
working on and uh that's why I wanted to
talk share our results with you today
it's joint work with Ali Raza of Allah I
hope he's here to take all the hard
questions as well as Ali maktumi and
azaraj malikian phenomenal researchers
I'm super delighted that I'm working
with them on this and Daron also joined
the team of group of Economics uh in the
second part of the talk I will talk
about some uh even more recent work in
which we are actually working with him
on so just as a quick motivation uh you
know if you look at online platforms a
future of many services are intricately
linked with consumer data and then this
is very much driven by the advances in
machine learning and AI which have
enabled huge promises in terms of you
know offering better services to
Consumers uh think about you know a more
refined search results personalized
recommendations informative ratings and
the list goes on and on and of course
given in this picture the demands for
data coming from corporations is
increasing and if you look at where this
data is coming from while some of it is
collected from publicly available
sources census or you know think about
different surveys American Community
surveys and demographics and so on much
of it is actually coming from uh users
actually sharing their personal data
while they're online on these online
platforms and this could sort of be in
the form of you know the data can be
shared as a byproduct of other
transactions as what happens with
Netflix and so on or actually in
exchange or free services that Google
Facebook and others provide but we're
also seeing actually more and more
explicit data Marcus Nielsen here is a I
think a market and data measurement uh
firm and sort of this is becoming more
and more of a reality and uh if you look
at sort of the trend uh the use and the
transactions associated with individual
data are almost certain to grow uh as
these social media applications new apps
new integrated Technologies spread but
also as you know we keep using more and
more uh Services enabled by Ai and as I
said this is generally taking place
automatically in your you know routine
online presence therefore creating
Myriad uh you know data externalities uh
in terms of you know you sharing your
data but also uh you know uh uh making a
lot of information available for other
users and this is the kind of data
externality that I think other actual
talk about in this Workshop uh later on
but basically all this makes privacy uh
a very uh important component of all of
these discussions uh as these uh you
know uh markets are more becoming a
reality so there are some key questions
that we want to sort of ask can
platforms secure some amount of privacy
to use as well still collecting data
there's a lot of policy discussions
around this question so we would like to
sort of think about what kind of
systematic framework uh you know uh as
you know quantitative people computer
scientists can we provide some framework
for thinking about these kinds of policy
discussions what kind of equilibrium
privacy guarantees can we provide and
will this be sufficient from welfare
optimality perspectives and what are the
architectures that actually emerge so
that we can guide design of some of
these markets as they shape up so the
setting is a simple one we're going to
think about a single platform and a
group of agents who obtain utility from
using this platform and they share their
data and the data will involve a common
component you know be represented by
some data random variable and there's
also going to be each user's own type so
Theta will be basically some group
specific common elements so think about
what group members value a service or I
think the way this way I think about
this is maybe it's a you know treatment
for a medical condition that everyone
will benefit from so everyone has some
data about but everyone will benefit
from and the users uh also have some
type uh that is more you know individual
information maybe it's irrelevant to
their demand maybe building this to pay
for services or type of ads that can be
shown to this user
so both of these dimensions are useful
for the platform but uh the individual
part could be costly for the users
because they don't want this information
about their own type be available to the
platform so that sort of uh the Privacy
violation they will incur if they share
their data and the other aspect that I
think is important to address and will
do so is this privacy violation for
individuals may vary across users uh
this is sort of you know my data may be
much less valuable than a you know more
important I don't know politicians data
so there's a sort of different price
sensitivities coming from different uh
uh constituencies in the system so I
will uh to address these questions I
will think about two relevant
environments these are two papers we've
been working on the first one will be
basically uh you know platforms can
directly or indirectly uh you know
acquire payments for that data
Acquisitions and this could happen when
there's an explicit data market or we
could also think about some free
services so there's some compensation
from the platform so think about that
being sort of the environment they're
considering in the second non-platforms
do not pay for data but they value uh
this data collection that the platform
engages in this is the common component
that they value they will all benefit
from a better estimate of that common
component and we're going to see
basically what kind of architectures
that would lead and in terms of you know
a little bit going more into the two
environments the first one allows for
exclusive payments and we will consider
there essentially currently you know
Common data architectures in particular
those that provide local and or
centralized differential privacy
guarantees and we will have
heterogeneous demands for privacy across
users and we will develop a you know
mechanism design approach in which uh
you know heterogeneous privacy
guarantees are provided to the users and
this mechanism design the mechanism will
also output and differentially private
optimal estimator as well as individual
compensation scheme for the users in the
second environment there are no payments
we will see you know what kind of data
architectures would be optimal uh what
about your optimality properties and in
particular we're going to see that
there's a well-defined class of
stochastic mechanisms in particular you
know shuffling mechanism which shuffles
the order of users Data before handing
it to the platform that can provide the
best privacy guarantee to users but we
will also see that even these mechanisms
do not guarantee that platforms will
actually stick with those user optimal
uh mechanisms because of game theoretic
interactions between the users and the
platform so that's so some of this is
going to come toward the end of the talk
I hope I can go all the way there I have
a lot as usual but I will try to get
into as many of the you know ideas that
we're sort of currently playing with as
possible
okay so uh something on related
literature there's a growing beautiful
literature on this question of data
acquisition from uh strategic privacy
conscious users I may be missing papers
if I'm doing so please let me know uh
you know I recently started reading and
I'm really uh you know fascinating
papers uh in in several of these papers
uh they use differential privacy to
quantify the cost incurred uh you know
when sharing data and there's a number
of papers uh in this area uh the one
that I would like to sort of highlight
uh it's sort of a very you know key
paper is Goshen wrote uh where you know
there's some assumption indeed that uh
you know there's some privacy conscious
users heterogeneous users and then they
design a mechanism to address a similar
question uh so there's some fundamental
differences in that here they take a
worst case view they're not
distributional assumptions on users data
or Price sensitivities and even though
they're genius user demands and their
interest in estimating the sum uh you
know of individuals data and that those
sort of assumptions together essentially
amount to the mechanism providing single
privacy guarantees so it doesn't quite
get into this notion of how do we do
heterogeneous guarantees across users
it's a sort of a more dominant strategy
type of view as opposed to more you know
a more Bayesian view that we're going to
adopt and there are many other papers uh
some are new uh uh and I think I'm
missing one paper that I want to include
here but it's in our paper uh but uh
that actually consider the same question
without differential privacy uh so
either you know they're considering some
menu of you know allocation price Pairs
and an optimize over those this is a
very nice paper comings where they
consider you know purchasing data from
uh users that provide different
accuracies different levels of
accuracies for data and strategically
price that access to the data so there's
there's a bunch of things and I think
our paper is a sort of different in in
the way that we're considering some
optimal Bayesian mechanisms we will see
that that approach leads to different
privacy levels for participating users
we're going to look at Central and local
architectures here this is our sort of I
think focus on what kind of
architectures uh you know and what are
their properties and then at the end um
sort of we're going to deviate a little
bit from differential privacy and say
without payment
um you know what what would user optimal
architectures look like and they're
going to sort of try to see the
implications of this shuffling
stochastic shuffling of user data and
what it would mean in a game theoretic
environment
so so that's sort of the landscape let
me dive into the uh dive into the uh
details so the model is superbly simple
uh we are we have a platform we have end
users the goal is to under estimate some
underlying parameter Theta and each user
has some individual data that's
informative about that data so data user
is Xi uh Theta is the common parameter
that you know we're trying to learn uh
and Zi is um you know individual uh you
know type that I was talking about let
me use alireza's example favorite
example I think that's sort of very
useful so Theta could be the effect of a
drug and Zi could be the blood sugar
level of an individual before the drug
and after the drug so you have access to
x i and you try to come up with some
estimate of your data by collecting this
data from the users okay so very sort of
simple estimation uh setup
uh and as I mentioned we're gonna do
sort of uh use differential privacy
first to sort of uh formalize these
privacy uh guarantees uh for user
demands the first one let me start with
Central differential privacy so this is
the idea this is a worst case guarantee
uh on you know the uh on the Privacy
demand of the user by limiting its
impact on the output of the platform's
estimation problem or more formally you
know you consider two data sets S and S
Prime which differ only in the item
components think about this as
representing I userized data and the
definition essentially says that the
impact of changing user Ida on the
algorithm's output is bounded from above
by e to the Epsilon I okay so there's an
upper bound on how this particular user
can impact the output and I get always
confused about what is Epsilon I so
smaller episode I essentially means that
user ID has less impact on the output
less impact means higher privacy
guarantee or lower privacy loss so
thinking about Epsilon parameter it will
be throughout our talk as the Privacy
Law level that the user is guaranteed so
algorithm a guarantees them a maximum
privacy most level of Epsilon I uh for
userite so that's Central DP uh so the
next one is also well in the central
case basically the way we structure the
book is there's a platform users trust
the platform to share their data only
require a guarantee on the output team
right so the platform completely follows
through with everything and we're
guaranteeing something on the output in
the local setting it's a sort of more
stringent uh requirement users don't
even trust the platform and user I share
is a completely private version of their
data which we denote by CI of X type so
this is a non-private input we privatize
each of the inputs separately and then
feed it into the platform and formally
we can actually guarantee that by just
saying that an algorithm is locally
differentially private if it takes these
private inputs uh sorry private data as
its input and has similar guarantee on
the output so it's basically as you can
see it the higher level of guarantee on
the private input and therefore you know
the fact the immediate fact is that
locally differentially private algorithm
is centrally differentially private so
it's basically more privacy guarantee
provided by this local differential
privacy and uh it sort of common way of
guaranteeing a differential privacy is
to add LaPlace noise to individual uh
you know uh just add LaPlace noise to
your estimate or individual data and let
me call that LaPlace uh noise or you
know variable has a distribution of this
sort with some parameter ETA
and if you think about for instance a
linear estimator uh with this LaPlace
mechanism it is in the form of take the
user data take a convex combination of
their data plus add noise LaPlace noise
and you can immediately see that if you
do that this is actually
ETA wi centrally differentially private
I just wrote a very simple you know this
is maybe dp101 but you can actually look
at the output of the algorithm you
change x i to x i Prime and clearly the
distribution of the LaPlace by doing
that changes by just this amount the bi
and w x i and then this is uh if you do
the cancellations this is less than or
equal to this oh I actually one thing I
wanted to mention sorry this I forgot I
have an assumption on the noise or or
the individual type I assume that
there's zero mean and they're bounded
and people ask me what happens when it's
unbounded and I will like there's a way
to address that as well so please ask
alireza or other
um so uh so basically in the stock we
assume that they are truncate they're
bounded so that allows us to bound this
term by one and therefore immediately
you have this Epsilon I or
ETA wi guarantee on the privacy laws so
this is one way of guaranteeing uh this
privacy by adding to the or linear
estimators of Laplace noise okay so what
I will do now is two parts uh in the
first environment uh so I will first
show that there's there's multiple
things here right we want to design an
optimal estimator we want to also figure
out optimal ways of acquiring uh
sensitive data or private data from the
user so the first part will be to figure
out suppose epsilons are given for fixed
set of epsilots what would be the
optimal estimator in the environment
that I just described and I will argue
that the linear estimators with the
LaPlace scheme are near optimal and then
in the second part I will endogenize
these epsilonize these are not fixed
we're going to ensure right that the
individuals have this kind of privacy
guarantees by I will endogenize by
giving a utility function to each of the
users I will Define what that utility
function looks like and then I will
input that into a mechanism design
problem and do that in both Central and
local settings so that's sort of what we
did in this first paper
so let me first quickly talk about uh
you know what do we mean by Optimal
estimators and uh for that we take the
Viewpoint of Minimax optimality which is
used uh you know uh quite a lot in the
statistics literature so we assume that
epsilons remember this is the Privacy
losses of these individuals are known
and basically our goal is to estimate
means of distributions we take a family
of distributions and then we assume that
this exci data are IID data drawn from
these distributions and we form an
estimator using this data and the
question is what is the optimal
estimator well we want to consider only
estimators in this class of centrally
differentially private estimators so the
me we need to optimize there and we
think about the area as a worst case
error which is that you know you look at
the mean square error of this estimator
uh this is the mean square error you
take the worst case overall possible
District attributions and you choose the
best estimator against that worst case
error so this is the min max uh kind of
you know worst case error that we're
trying to uh you know uh optimize and
our first result essentially says that
uh for distributions where you have this
upper bound on your X
there is the lower bound on that min max
error
and moreover there exists some centrally
differentially private linear estimators
that achieve that lower bound up to log
n uh uh value so this looks a little uh
you know uh
I don't know mathematically messy but I
just want to give you quickly how we
actually go because I think it's a very
cool trick how you uh you know come up
with these lower bounds
um I will just give you sort of the main
idea of uh the proof uh but uh before
that let me uh just mention that when
all the epsilonize are equal like you
don't have these heterogeneous
activities everybody has equal uh
Epsilon the lower bound reduces to uh
bound that was actually in duchy as well
as dork and Roth and this is a typo it's
supposed to be a maximum I was going to
fix this but I forgot so it's basically
the Mac you can just put Epsilon size
equal to some Epsilon here that will
give you a k Square Epsilon square and
the maximum is either at 0 or n which
gives you basically maximum of one or n
or one over n Square Epsilon Square so
that's our bound and let me tell you how
we got to this lower bound quickly so
the trick is to relate that lower bound
problem to a hypothesis testing problem
and I hope I don't lose people here
because but it's actually uh it's a cool
trick so I will go over it but if you
get lost I'm happy to come back to that
to talk about it it's not super key but
anyway so um essentially remember we
were trying to lower bound the in
minimum overall estimators the supremum
of the error right so since it's the
minimum it suffices to show that for any
estimator you have the lower bound uh so
and then this is over the maximum
overall distributions I picked two
distributions P1 and P2 this is the P1
and P2 and they're me and I call gamma
the difference between their means to
gamma the difference between their means
so this is for a particular distribution
okay so instead of the Supreme Memorial
distributions I lower bounded by the
average of this error in these two
distributions
okay and this is the average of the mean
square error Theta hat minus Theta for
that PJ for that particular distribution
I simplify this by instead of thinking
about the Distribution on the data x i
call Y to be the Distribution on the
estimator Theta hat so then this is
equal to over that q y minus Theta PJ
this I did nothing here I just said p is
the Distribution on data Q is the
corresponding distribution for the
estimator
and this is a sort of the again the mean
square error I use a Markov inequality
to say that this is bounded From Below
by the probability of uh y minus Theta
being greater than equal to gamma
and then uh basically you can view this
property as and probably don't error for
the nearest neighbor classifier so you
can ask the following question given
some means given some realization Theta
have is it coming from Theta P1 or is it
coming from data P2 so if it's you know
gamma close to one it's going to come
from here gonna be close to one so it's
the nearest neighbor type of argument
but you can show that the error for this
kind of uh you know question hypothesis
testing question is given by the error
probability of you know coming from one
versus the other distribution
okay so so that's sort of the first uh
step of getting from here to this kind
of error probability for some hypothesis
testing problem of this sort and then
there's a beautiful method from
statistics like hands method that
actually lower bounds such error
probability by a distribution distance
on q1 and Q2 TV distance okay and so far
actually what I've been talking about
are classical tricks I think the main uh
you know contribution in the paper is to
actually show that when you have
differential privacy kind of constraints
you can put the distance on these
distributions by two terms
part of the term is coming from
differential privacy and the TV distance
on P1 and P2 and part of it comes from
data stochasticity and comes from a KL
Divergence between those two
distributions so so basically we we sort
of Identify two sources of you know
stochasticity some coming from
differential privacy some coming from
data stochasticity enabled that to come
up with a refined bound on this
distribution difference and then
remember I chose P1 and P2 to be
arbitrary distributions I choose them as
you know specific Bernoulli
distributions that gives me this upper
Bound for those particular P1 and P2 now
I can put this back in my lower bound
you will get something in terms of gamma
which was another free parameter and uh
basically optimizing our gamma gives you
the lower bound that I have presented
before Okay so
sort of a couple of steps but I mean I
think a cool technique to come up with
lower bounds on such min max uh uh error
terms when you're thinking about optimal
estimators so this was just for the
lower bound and now for the upper bound
or sorry for the achievability result we
basically said remember that the linear
estimator of this sort achieves a
central differential private but also
achieves optimality and essentially that
comes from I will go into a little bit
more now but the bound remember was
this Max of this kind of thing with the
K ranging from zero to n you can write
this for a particular case Star as the
minimum of 1 over n minus K star and 1
over uh this particular chart here and
then basically then this is the lower
bound and the rest uh essentially of
achievability comes from figuring out
that if you think about all of your data
X1 to extend
the first part X1 to x k star you can
actually make them differentially
private by setting the weights wi data
to equal to Epsilon I and you can show
that that contributes exactly to this
error and then this part basically comes
from you know setting the rest to data
stochasticity so you set the rest equal
to you know uh all these weights equal
and they contribute a term of 1 over n
minus K star to your uh error level and
then you need to choose K star in a way
that you know there are two error terms
remember coming from differential
privacy and data stochasticity there's
some point of K star at which one of
them starts dominating the other one so
you choose K star to to exactly figure
out where one is you know more
influential than the other error and
that gives you essentially uh uh exactly
this lower bound showing that this kind
of linear estimator achieves that lower
bound so
I hope this was clear I can't see
everyone to be able to go over wherever
it might not be clear but this is just
to give you an idea of how this could be
uh proved and you can use similar
arguments I don't want to go into the
detail but uh in the case of local
differential privacy you can show that
similar arguments uh linear estimator
with LaPlace mechanism indeed is also
min max optimal uh in this setting so
once we achieve that you know this
linear estimators are min max optimal I
will now go into the mechanism design
problem remember so far I just said
epsilons are uh you know
exogenously given I'm going to
endogenize them to do that I will
basically say that each user has a type
CI which represents his prime his or her
privacy sensitivity this is per unit
cost of privacy loss for user right I'm
going to assume that each CI is
independently drawn from some
distribution fi and I will say that all
of this CI is the C Vector so this is
the vector of privacy sensitivities and
I will consider mechanism them are
individuals participate by sharing their
data and Reporting their privacy
sensitivity
so there's an assumption I'm making here
I assume that users can lie about their
privacy sensitivity they can say that I
actually care a lot about privacy you
know that's something they strategically
lie about but we assume that they cannot
manipulate their data so this is
basically a is an assumption that will
hold for instance if the platform is the
one that's actually you know collecting
the data so as long as you participate
your data is scooped or it can be
verified somehow it would be interesting
to see you know if that could also be
manipulated for you know this kind of
utility construction but that's not what
we do in this paper
and then depending on the reported
sensitivities platform provides a
compensation for the user which is TI
and that's a function of the entire
reported privacy sensitivities and then
mechanism spits out privacy loss levels
as well as the freshly private estimator
okay so that's our mechanism basically
you have this data XI you have the CI so
as you as I said before in the beginning
comparing to other papers in the
literature we're making distributional
assumptions here and then user reports
uh CI to be the CI Prime you know that's
his report and then also shares the data
x i or x i hat depending on whether it's
a central or local architecture and the
mechanism outputs all of these things
that I already mentioned okay so let's
go now to write down first to cost
function
so uh again user shares the data with
the platform that's the benefit he gets
right by leading to a lower estimation
error on the common part but incurate
privacy cost because there's going to be
some leakage of privacy and we use the
we Define cost instead of utility that's
easier to work with and we basically say
from the participation there's some mean
square error uh that you know you you
incur coming from the common part and
that you have some privacy cost which is
your type actual type CI not your report
that's you know how much you incur
that's the actual type and then the
Privacy loss that will be output by the
mechanism which is a function of your
report CI Prime minus the compensation
you receive note we're doing cost so we
just turned it into a minus composition
and then the mean square error is
basically exactly the estimator minus
Theta and note I also put here
dependencies on CI Prime and C minus I
because the Epsilon that the mechanism
outputs depend on the CI Prime and C
minus
and then if you don't participate in the
mechanism you have nothing just your own
data so your best estimate given your
data alone is just your variance x i
minus Theta this is the variance of the
noise so that's your group essentially
dictate your participation uh
constraints okay so this is cost
function and the mechanism design
problem is the platform will minimize an
objective function which is given by
mean square plus total payments it makes
to all the users there's Revelation
principle here I'm actually going over a
lot of things that assuming some
knowledge background and mechanism
design but basically you can just assume
that a direct Revelation mechanism where
individuals report their type truthfully
is a base in Nash equilibrium and we we
this is without loss of generality we
can you know constrain ourselves to
mechanisms of this sort and we formalize
this by imposing an incentive
compatibility constraint ensuring that
truthful reporting is the base in Nash
equilibrium and an individual
rationality constraints making sure that
uh platforms does not make users worse
off by participating so the mechanism
design problem then is minimize this
objective function of the platform
subject to IC constraints for users each
user is better off reporting his
truthful type While others are reporting
correctly and also his costs for
participating is less than or equal to
his outside option okay so very uh you
know
uh that is the word uh the innocent
looking problem except that it's highly
non-convex it's infinite dimensional we
need to minimize over all possible
estimators all possible privacy levels
we guarantee as well as all possible
payments
anyway but uh I think the the analysis
uh is uh actually has a lot of
similarities to myerson's seminal work
uh basically we first figure out so sort
of some characterization on optimal
payments uh optimal intern payments uh
by using the first order optimality
conditions of this problem uh you just
say that the payments optimal payments
need to take this form as a function of
Epsilon so this is a trick right you try
to reduce the dimension of your
optimization problem first you'll get
rid of the payments you write everything
in terms of epsilons for any estimator
and then you plug this back into uh uh
you know your optimization problem
there's some free parameter here uh
which is you know it's a free parameter
for all optimal payments but because
you're looking for the optimal mechanism
of course you want to minimize that so
you set that equal to zero so then you
put everything together and rewrite
things in terms of some virtual costs
this is also for those who know Myerson
will look familiar not the same but
familiar and then you know we get rid of
the payments this way this becomes only
a minimization in epsilons now and the
optimal estimator and then we assume
virtual cost is increasing again this is
similar to myerson's uh you know uh
monotonistic condition but once we do
that then we basically focus on linear
estimators here from now on and for a
linear estimator uh you know for Central
differential private I'm going to assume
this linear plus LaPlace noise and I
will write the mean square error
corresponding to such an estimator that
simplifies my problem even further
um
okay it's uh so that's the problem that
you need to solve to be able to figure
out all of these uh parameters now the
problem is it's still non-convex
um so unlike uh Myers and now it's still
a nasty problem because you have also
estimators and stuff but I mean these
guys are amazing in dealing with the
nasty problems you can just uh show that
this can be solved efficiently it has
beautiful structure in it that it can
actually be sold efficiently in time and
look at so I hope this approach is clear
and then you know you can do the same
thing with local mechanisms you just
have a different mean square error you
plug that back in and in this case we
weren't able to get efficient guarantees
for the exact solution but you can come
up with an episode approximate solution
in polynomial time in n and one over
Epsilon so okay so that's essentially
algorithmic characterization of these
two architectures and then one asks can
ask the question of what two platforms
and users uh prefer and uh okay I'm
running out of time badly so I will just
say that you know from the platform's
perspective you can look at the uh uh
you know which of the architectures
gives better uh objective function value
for the platform it turns out Central
differential privacy does that and it's
not too uh you know uh it's actually
intuitive because if you think about it
local differential system private
estimator is more stringent is more
stringent guarantees so platform
actually can use a central differential
private architecture uh to get a better
mean square error and payments uh using
a central differential architecture and
for users you can do some nice
comparative Statics and see that
depending on their privacy sensitivity
they may prefer Central versus local uh
architectures and different users may
have different preferences for doing so
I think this there's much more to do
here in terms of comparing these
architectures and seeing sort of from
platform and user perspective which ones
are prefer I'm happy to discuss that
more offline
um
okay this I was going to talk about
another paper okay that won't happen but
I will try to maybe tell you a little
bit about uh what this is about so so
far everything was in terms of
differential privacy right I fixed the
differential privacy guarantees that
gave me optimal estimators in terms of
Central and local differential private
estimators so it's important I think
going forward to understand what other
data architectures could provide
optimality properties and in what forms
so to study that we will actually place
and think about the different game
theoretic environment now in which users
can actually decide not to share their
data remember in the previous model they
were able to do that through their
participation in the mechanism this is
without them without an explicit prices
or mechanism Design This is a choice we
give to the users I will use a different
metric for value of data and that's
called revealed information and you know
in our group at least we have very
heated discussions on whether that's the
right notion or differential privacy is
the right notion to think about uh you
know while thinking about design of data
architectures I will just make a maybe a
comment that while differential privacy
has been great it really provides this
worst case upper bound type guarantee so
if you're thinking about game theoretic
analysis where you need to write utility
functions I mean you're trying to
provide optimal data architectures the
upper bounding arguments don't Bode very
well so this is the reason why we
actually went and started thinking about
the different notion for leakage of
privacy and I will hopefully tell you at
least what that is and then I will try
to show you the user optimal data
architecture using this kind of set and
then there's no explicit prices so
that's essentially trying to capture the
fact that right now on many platforms
there's still limits on what kind of
explicit payments you can provide to the
users okay so given that let me just
tell you maybe two three things and then
wrap up key things so the first one is
this revealed information notion
remember the model we had was exactly
theta plus di each data as a common
component and then you know private
component revealed information is we
took mean Square there could be other
things it's basically the reduction in
mean square error before and after
observing the mechanism's output so you
have some variance on your Theta this is
how much you know about data right you
can think about it
without seeing anything from this
platform or from this mechanism you put
it through some mechanism and you learn
things about data and basically this is
how much you learn so this is the
revealed information because you have
this mechanism and you can also Define
Zi
revealed information about the private
types very similarly using this accent
and exposed uh you know distribution of
approach as opposed to this worst case
DP approach so that's how we Define
revealed information and the other thing
I want to Define is a shuffling
mechanism this is also just to contrast
it with this differential privacy where
you're adding noise right this is a
different way of adding noise and I
think in a game theoretic environment at
least in the first you know modeling
sense it makes sense so we have users
and each user decides to share their
data or not with some probability Qi so
this is their decision Qi and then you
turn it into you put out input all of
this decisions into a shuffler which
actually takes a permutation or shuffles
the order of the data and we call that
Sigma 1 to Sigma n and that's what is
given to the platform okay so this is a
particular mechanism that takes the user
input and turns it into you know what
you're going to feed into the platform
and and one thing that I put here in red
is we assume in this particular
mechanism that all of the data is
shuffled even if you know some of them
are not shared but you know you have
something and you can't look into it the
shuffler just shuffles everything even
though some of them may be empty it
doesn't contain user data I'm defining
this because I'll say this is the
optimal one from user perspective
so essentially that's the first result
which says that this full shuffling
mechanism that I just described is user
optimal and that's in code because
that's in a Pareto optimal sense in the
in the sense that for any mechanism
there's an inevitable leakage of privacy
information that is bounded From Below
by how much you can learn about the
common part of the data and that's sort
of this line exactly in this space of
privacy cost and level of learning and
moreover the shuffling the full
shuffling mechanism achieves the
spiritual boundary by thinking about q1
to qn equal to some q and each queue
achieves a different point in that
region so
that's the optimal
I will uh I will skip the proof now I'm
going to put this into a completely game
theoretic environment in the sense that
I will also give some agency to the
platform I will assume that platform now
has a parameter which actually it
decides this is the shuffling parameter
it commits to shuffle each user's data
with probability mu so it says given the
Yi I will Shuffle it with probability
meal and I will not Shuffle it and I
will immediately get it with a property
one minus mu
so this is to think about extreme cases
if mu is for instance zero that means
I'm not going to shuffle your data at
all I'm going to take it as this right
so this is actually a privacy guarantee
that the platform uh Promises to the
users and I'm knowing this mu users
decide on whether or not they're going
to share their data so it's a two-stage
game platform chooses new users chooses
uh whether or not they're going to share
their data and then I'm gonna do the
same thing as I did before I'm going to
you know give some utilities for the
users this is going to be the utility of
revealed information about common
component minus
this utility of you know revealed
information about your private site and
platform values both components and we
put some parameter Delta about how much
it you know values data versus Di and so
on and then I'm not going to Define it
but the you know we Define it Nash user
equilibrium given the Muse and then you
know stackable equilibrium for the
platform to optimize uh over mu and then
you know you can do uh you can do
interesting things with this equilibrium
in particular you can show that uh
actually uh at equilibrium as the users
oh sorry this is just a characterization
of the equilibrium so you can do a
characterization of the stackable
equilibrium in that you know you look at
the alpha parameter which is how much
users care about learning and there's
some Alpha bar and Alpha upper bar such
that below that the stackable
equilibrium is to provide full privacy
guarantee and above that to provide no
guarantee and in between this is just
some you know this is not linear
actually it's just a cartoon is is just
decreasing in some manner from one to
zero so that's how the stackleberg
equilibrium looks and then you know
there's very weird paradoxical things
happening in this equilibrium
essentially one that I will highlight
quickly and then wrap up after that is
that you know as Alpha increases as
users care more about learning
their utility should increase right
keeping the platforms action fixed if
the platform is using the same action
that gives the same equilibrium and as
Alpha increases utility increases but it
turns out that in equilibrium as users
care more about this common data uh
actually uh the
overall platform equilibrium makes user
utility worse off and that can be seen
by actually this characterization of the
equilibrium in that you know when it
Alpha increases the Privacy costs uh uh
this privacy cost that uh the platform
is extracting from the users abruptly
decreases and even though users gain
more from learning because platform is
exploiting this it actually
extracts much more privacy loss from the
users and therefore making their overall
utility worse off and then I will not
talk about this because it will take me
another five minutes basically we
started also asking the question of when
do platforms deviate from user optimal
architecture the uh you know this kind
of uh taking advantage of privacy losses
of users actually makes the platform
deviate from this user optimal
architectures and do things that make
users significantly worse off compared
to what their optimal would be in
equilibrium and I think this is a very
interesting area to think about what
data architectures actually create
tensions between you know platform and
user viewpoints and how can we think
about you know
not using those that further Empower
platforms when we're thinking about uh
you know uh
getting the benefit of learning yet you
know thinking about all these privacy
costs at the same time anyway I will
conclude and I'm hopefully not too much
over time so the goal was to think about
design of mechanisms for acquiring data
from privacy conscious users who also
you know benefit from this data sharing
so there's this tension between data
sharing and privacy we consider two
setups with explicit payments and no
payments and try to think about optimal
architectures and I think there's a lot
that I feel our community can think
about that's why I wanted to share this
work thinking about how to design
incentives how to trade off multiple
performance metrics can we think about
different learning objectives than just
the linear estimation problem can we
think about more nuanced models that
takes us Beyond differential privacy and
further performance metrics can we think
about in these kinds of situations so
with that maybe I'll stop and see if
there are questions
thanks so much that was a fantastic talk
uh people in the room you can clap with
your little Avatar or you could clap
your physical room with your hands
um
so uh
yeah I we I have some time for questions
if possibly does and um
I mean as long as I don't disrupt the
program uh yeah no but I please do
either navigate to a mic you can ask you
if you stop screen sharing people
um Can can then walk around uh and then
you can navigate to a mic to ask a
question if you're in the physical room
you can also ask a question with these
microphones
oh I had a question so the model seems
to assume that the user data is IID if
the user data is not IID then
differential privacy is no longer kind
of a worst case
compared to the variance mod the
revealed I can't remember we called it
um
say that again
I only heard your part maybe you should
come in front of the laptop oh uh
hello I'm Tony yeah so it seems like the
you're making this assumption that the
user data is kind of IID or the noise is
IID yep and if that's not true
then differential privacy doesn't
provide an upper bound anymore
uh compared to the in the state of this
revealed I can't remember called the
reveal revealed information because the
correlations between agents can reveal
more information about a person than
than is differentially
yeah it's according to differential
privacy so just wondering if you had
thought about that tension at all and
where the future direction is
uh that's a fantastic question uh we
have taught about it but we haven't done
anything about it I think uh you know
the fact that the you know your privacy
sensitivity depends on the data you're
sharing you know uh is a very natural
correlation that one should think about
in these kinds of models we haven't done
anything about that yet we would like to
uh I think this revealed information
setup provides uh you know uh a natural
framework for thinking about perhaps
that kind of correlation uh
I mean
my answer is I don't know the answer we
haven't done it but I think that
studying that kind of correlation what
kind of you know uh
preferences that would lead from user
perspective from platform perspective
would be very interesting to study and I
would do it in the revealed information
framework because that allows the
sighting to be able to work with those
correlations
and with your other actually I think
we'll talk a little bit it's not
correlation between data and privacy but
other actual talk about some of the
correlations between data externalities
in her talk with I think so it's
possible to use this kind of framework
to address that question and it would be
very interesting to do so
awesome Uh Kevin you can unmute and ask
your question
question about the second paper you
presented so if I understand correctly
there the um the IR constraint
represents if someone opts out then they
do not have access to this like estimate
that gets you know uh produced and if
someone opts in then you know I send
them the same so that reduces their
error right yeah so so I'm wondering
that context it are you know instead of
paying users different amounts um based
on the reports can you then instead of
that use like different kinds of
information design tricks or like I send
you more distorted estimates or you know
very difficult and SMS and you instead
of using like the monetary payment
Dimension to ensure like would that be a
cheaper way to do things
um
possibly I don't know if it's going to
be cheaper but that's actually a very
interesting idea instead of payment one
can think about you know uh providing
different levels of accuracy on the
common components yes I mean if you're
able to do that for
eign
thinking about providing different
levels of accuracy uh
and that would be very interesting to
try out
awesome thank you uh I think uh if there
are any other questions maybe you can
type them in the chat
um alien azaraj are uh yes online so
they can definitely answer questions and
also if you want to stick around we're
going to have a break after evanstalk
and uh thank you people can walk up to
you individually in the auditorium to uh
ask questions so thank you so much thank
you Nicole great to see you all
um this was a lot of fun things thank
you thank you bye-bye
uh so Evan you can um walk up to the
podium and